almost no one seems to realize that the
head of bioethics at the NIH the person
who was supposed to make sure that fauci
behaves ethically is his wife what the
hell is his wife this whole time
gain of function in this context is just
another way of saying bio weapon some
good nuggets in an article important to
note that fauci author 2012 paper
arguing for gain of function research
Obama wisely put this on pause but fauci
restarted it so go back to Wikipedia
let's read a Wikipedia a little bit more
okay so zoom in go go actually to her
Wikipedia this is the ghetto version of
it go to the real version of it this is
just pedia yeah go to go to file go to
yeah right there so let's read the zoom
in zoom in zoom in let's read it
together guys we're gonna have a quick
uh reading here Grady uh was born and
raising German okay graduate go to
Career go to Career Grady has worked in
nursing clinical research and clinical
care with a special realization in HIV
she was a commissioner on the
presidential commission and uh for the
study bioethical issues from 2012 to
2017. uh that's Obama until Trump showed
up and she probably got fired Grady is a
member of the uh National maybe she got
a promotion great to remember the
National Academy of Medicine a senior
fellow at the Kentucky Institute of
ethics and a fellow of the Hastings
Center and American Academy of nursing
she received the National Institutes of
Health CEO award in 2017 and the
director's award from the same
organization in 2015 and 17 grade he was
married to Anthony fauci an American
immunologist and a head of National
Institute of allergy and infectious
diseases at the National Institute of
Health they have three daughters
together a little weird what do you mean
a little weirdo I I I actually want to
give you some feedback on tell me okay
the more and more I read all this I'm
just going back to your theory on
alliances
there's a entire alphabet soup of
alliances right there the NIH the CIA
the DEH the boy they're the FDA the FBI
is all connected
fauci whether he is guilty or not guilty
of doing whatever it is based on those
alliances of all the alphabet soup
that's going on there Untouchable
nothing's happening exactly I said that
has happened listen to me Untouchable
and you know what's crazy he yells at
people when he's in Congress by the way
why don't you type in fouchy wife Snopes
okay fauci wife Snopes let's maybe
there's is that Snopes due to personally
approve defies no now that one
inspection a post falsely link found
she's wife to FDA vaccine know that Dr
fauci's wife Reuters no I I want to know
if Anthony is the head of U.S and food
and yeah they're not even so if you go
on Snopes and you type in fauci
uh uh uh uh fauci that's insane wife
um
did Biden some things
yeah I mean look they if they don't even
have a story on it you know that's even
a bigger concern that they're not even
addressing it anyways I don't know I
think I think it's not good protocol in
the company for the HR to be the wife
and the guys making all the decisions
just kind of sitting there especially
when you and I taxpayers are paying for
it you know if you're sitting there
saying what's wrong with that again
you're part of the problem yeah I I
agree 100 like and now but and I said
this the other day bioethics what do you
like she's it's not even that it's like
I said this the other day now
everybody's like with Elon with the
Twitter with the dumps and everything is
out we know now it's like hey we got you
it's like The Wizard of Oz Pat the
curtains open now we see oh look at what
you what you [ __ ] were doing and now
nothing's gonna happen the Republicans
are gonna take the house what are they
gonna do they're gonna sit them down in
the chair Congress they're all going to
yell the Democrats are going to stick up
for them because they use him to bring
in their [ __ ] the Republicans are just
gonna bark my butt nothing will happen
fauci is going to walk free because Adam
you nailed it his Alliance is bro he's
Untouchable yeah Untouchable bro his
wife is HR yeah that's right that's like
the uh The Wizard of Oz at the end of
the day he's married to the chief of
police you're good dude yeah don't worry
about it nothing's gonna happen Pat
you're an odds guy obviously I don't I
think it's fair to say
that you're not a fan of fauci fair
I'm not a fan of anybody that puts Force
got it yeah you're an odds guy I'm I you
know I like to reference Vegas for odds
what are the odds that fauci will face
any penalties criminals uh uh monetarily
exactly feet fines any and he finds
criminal anything like that fauci faces
any of that less than five percent oh
you're even putting it that high yeah
less than five percent less than five is
I mean
when you're a bureaucrat like like uh
fauci is and you've been around for how
many presidencies seven he's been around
he's been around for a long time my
question is this like do they basically
sit you down and say Hey listen what you
whatever we want you to do you're
because you're the voice you're the head
doctor
of the NIH whatever you say is set in
stone you do this and no matter what
you're gonna you're never gonna see one
day inside of a jail cell do you think
that that conversation happens or is is
an unsaid Untold thing where they're
just like hey bro you're a Democrat we
we got you just don't ever F us up you
know what I mean do you think that
conversation happens Pat with him with
him no you don't think by the way here's
here's what I do think uh what I do
think will happen when you and I are 62
years old okay we're gonna be at the
movie theaters watching a movie called
Avatar 30. covet 19. you know that's
what the movie's gonna be called no joke
I'm telling you okay he's gonna be dead
and someone's gonna have the courage to
make a movie on some kind of a
streamlined service that's you know on
the right and we're gonna sit there and
we're going to watch everything about
falching you're gonna say get the hell
out of here
and and most people are gonna be like ah
who cares life moves on yeah it was 20
years ago I don't give a [ __ ] about this
but some of us are going to care about
it like for example Argo when I watched
the movie Argo with Ben Affleck there's
a scene where they're going to the
Embassy and they're getting them out my
dad watched that movie emotional because
his sister was in the embassy when they
came in and she left and married a
marine or some soldier in the U.S she
left she went to Ohio yeah she left the
entire my dad's like I had to go pick
her up and I have to do this and I have
to do that so but it took 30 something
years until CIA was able to make the
movie Argo so maybe we're gonna see the
I said 62 years old I think we're going
to be 74 years old when we see that
movie so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
[Music]